Musik
Florentin Will, Stefan Tietze, tolle Gäste, sexy Vize, sie lachen, lernen, entdecken und was machst du so? Ich höre das Podcast UFO. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von dem Podcast UFO. Schön, dass ihr da seid und was ihr gerade gehört habt, war das fantastische Intro von Markus. Vielen Dank, das ist so ein hohes Kante-Intro, das liegt bei uns schon lange auf dem Teller, aber heute haben wir es mal rausgehauen. Vielen Dank, eines der besten, würde ich sagen bis jetzt. Ich habe gedacht, das haben wir schon ein paar Mal gespielt, aber es ist schon gut. Es ist richtig gut, aber es klingt auch wie manche anderen. Nicht, dass es deutlich schlechter wird. Es gibt aber auch ein spezielles Outro, also bleibt bis zum Ende der Folge dran, wenn ihr das hören wollt. Richtig gut, wir müssen jetzt auch mit so Influencer-Strategien anfangen. Lasst einen Daumen da, lasst einen Kommentar da. Hallo Stefan. Hallo Florentin. Heute haben wir eine ganz besondere Folge für euch vorbereitet, denn... Ich finde, man merkt schon, man merkt, dass uns beiden die schwere Last
der Podcast-Maloche abgenommen
wurde. Wir sind völlig entspannt, wir
kommen nur hierher und wir
lassen einfach laufen, aber die harte Arbeit, die
hinter so einem Podcast steckt, das wissen ja viele nicht,
die wurde uns abgenommen, denn wir haben
seit dieser Woche eine
Praktikantin, die uns
unterstützt bei unseren täglichen Aufgaben
und die uns eine grosse Hilfe ist bis jetzt, deswegen können wir uns eigentlich nur auf den inneren Kern konzentrieren. In diesem Sinne herzlich willkommen beim Podcast-UFO Schülerpraktikantin Thais. Hey, herzlich willkommen. Oh, was? Oh, da ist niemand? Moment. Niemand spricht? Wo ist sie denn? Komisch. Warst du in deinem Praktikum schon mal zu spät damals? Wir hatten doch gesagt, 19 Uhr Aufnahme. Wir hatten doch gesagt, Arbeitsbeginn 19 Uhr. Tja. Entschuldigung, wenn dein Arbeitsbeginn um 19 Uhr ist und du zu spät kommst, weil du, und das ist der einzige Grund, warum du zu spät kommst, verschlafen hast, läuft was falsch in deinem Leben. Tja, Thais ist leider zu spät, verspätet sich heute ein wenig, er wird hoffentlich noch überhaupt zur Aufnahme erscheinen. Aber ohne Scheiß, das werden wir thematisieren. Wir werden das Thema, die sind, wir werden das auch knallhart, also wirklich mit dicken roten Stift in ihren Praktikumsbericht schreiben. Mit einem dicken, fetten, roten Stift. So geht's nicht, schreiben wir. Nimmermehr, so geht's nimmermehr. Ich war bei meinem Praktikum nie zu spät. Es war aber auch, muss man sagen, so ein bisschen so eine Drucksituation, weil ich bin nicht im Lokalbereich untergekommen, bei der Zeitung damals, sondern beim Lokalsport. Und da gab es nur so einen, der war die Etage drüber, aber die war nicht so richtig ausgebaut, das heißt, es war sehr kühl, und da war einfach so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein, ich das jetzt? 8 zu 1 nach 20 Minuten, was ist das für ein Verb? Aber ich verstehe, dass da irgendwann gehen einem die Wörter aus. Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Also wenn du das ernst nimmst, diesen Beruf, glaube ich, kannst du nur verlieren, weil irgendwann gehen dir die, sag mir fünf Wörter für Tor. Ja, Tor, Kasten, Box, Kiste und Stahlrahmen. So, und dann wird es auch schon lächerlich. Aber Stahlrahmen wird zu lächerlich, da schalten Leser ab, da sagen die, was ist mit eurem Lokalteil los, eurem Sportteil. Und deswegen, ich fand das immer so ein bisschen befremdlich da, aber trotzdem war ich nie zu spät. Es hat mir gar keinen Spaß gemacht, null. Und ich hörte, Tharisa hat einen Haufen Spaß. Du, das hat eine Menge Spaß. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Wir haben sie noch nie gesehen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie überhaupt existiert, weil noch ist sie nicht erschienen. Mal schauen. Ich habe damals im Deutschen Museumpraktikum gemacht und ich weiß noch, es ist immer gut, wenn solche Erfahrungen gut anfangen, ich weiß noch, ich war da an der Pforte
und hab dann so gesagt, ja, ich bin hier für
Herrn sowieso von der Luftfahrtabteilung
und dann die Empfangsdame hat
dann da irgendjemand angerufen,
ja, guten Tag, Herr sowieso, Ihre Praktikantin
ist jetzt hier. Was?
Das kann nicht wahr sein.
Sehr gut, das war noch in meiner langen Haarephase.
Wirklich? Ja.
Ich bin unangebietig, wenn sie sagt, Will, Will, W-I-L-L und man merkt schon so, manche Informationen sind nicht angekommen. Vielleicht haben die nicht mehr mein Praktikum. Es gibt ja so Impulspraktika. Jemand fragt dich, kann ich bei dir ein Praktikum machen? Und du sagst, ja klar. Und du vergisst es und zwei Wochen später steht die Person tatsächlich vor der Tür. So war es natürlich bei uns nicht. So war es natürlich nicht bei uns. Wir waren da knall drauf vorbereitet. Es gab ein RTF-Dokument, wo Aufgaben drinstehen, es gab Ideen, was wir mit ihr machen, es gab tolle Fragen, es gab Fragen von Flotin, hat sich Mühe gegeben, muss man sagen. Gibt das nicht selten. Alles in seinem Leben flowt so vorbei an ihm.
Und man muss sagen, du hast nicht oft, also angenommen, du bist in so einem Fluss und du versuchst gar nicht, nach dem nächsten Ast oder nach dem Rand zum Rand zu schwimmen. Du lässt dich mittreiben. Dein Leben ist ein Fluss.
Und da muss ich sagen, hast du dir kurz irgendwie den Ast geschnappt und hast dann den festgehalten und hast den schönen, ich muss sagen, schwierig, diese, weil sie nach Hause zu fahren, aber du hast so was Schönem geschnitzt und hast dir plötzlich Mühe gegeben. Aber dieser Ast ist nur zwei Wochen bei uns. Naja, jedenfalls wurde ich gefragt, ob wir der was zu essen besorgen müssen, was ich sehr süss fand.
Es war die grosse, etwas verunsichert wirkende Frage in dem RTF-Dokument. Müssen wir was zu essen besorgen? Wie ist die versichert? Ah, okay, über Schule, habe ich herausgefunden. Ich habe einen PDF gefunden vom Arbeitsamt der Agentur, da steht drauf, was man wissen muss, aber da steht nur drauf, was man als Praktikant oder Praktikantin machen muss und wissen muss, aber nicht als Arbeitgeber. Muss man dem Essen geben, trinken? Woher haben die die Information? Die denken sich, die machen das, die stellen die Regeln auf. Ja, aber wenn du Fragen im Internet recherchierst, kriegst du die Information nur für eine Seite immer. Das stimmt, ja. Wo sind die Informationen, woher wissen Menschen Dinge? Das ist meine Frage, glaube ich, auf die ich hinaus will. Weil woher wissen Leute wie wir, wir müssen jetzt recherchieren, was muss ich zu meinem Praktikum morgen mitbringen, aber eigentlich wollen wir wissen, was bringt Thais mit, was müssen wir ihr kaufen. Ist das Internet generell subjektiv, würde ich sagen, wenn du zum Beispiel auf Wikipedia-Seite von Lemur gehst, dann ist es ja aus der Perspektive des Menschen geschrieben, nicht aus der Perspektive des Lemurs, nicht die Ich-Perspektive, da steht nicht, ich habe langes Fell, ich habe vier Beine, sondern es ist nicht. Ich kann weder Deutsch noch schreiben, noch weisig, dass ich existiere. Ja, ich kann fast nichts, habe aber grosse, grosse Augen. Klar, alles ist subjektiv, klar. Ich meine, worüber reden wir? Alles ist subjektiv, wie das zu sagen. Auch Mathematik? Du, als ich diesen Eulen-Artikel, du musst dir vorstellen, Lexikon-Artikel entstehen ja auch, jemand muss Sätze schreiben, jemand muss die schreiben, jemand muss überlegen, fang ich jetzt mit dem Verb an, ganz crazy, es ist halt einfach so, jemand muss Entscheidungen getroffen haben und das ist ja immer subjektiv. Ich glaube, Lexikonschreiben ist extrem repetitiv. Du hast gerade von der Lokalpresse gesprochen und ich glaube, aber Lexikon ist noch schlimmer, weil du immer sagst, Birne, eine Birne ist Banane, eine Banane ist. Und dann ist der Fakt, wie kann man das denn ein bisschen aufpeppen, wie kann man da sagen, gelb, gekrümmt und köstlich auf der Zunge. Ihr werdet es nicht glauben, aber dieses Obst heisst Banane. Beim Bundestag kannst du ja, boah, die lässt sich echt Zeit, ne?
Gut, aber beim Bundestag kannst du ja, boah, die lässt hier echt Zeit, ne?
Aber beim Bundestag kannst du ja einfache Sprache auswählen.
Ich find gut, weil Wikipedia interessante Sprachen stünde.
Genau, schwierige Sprache.
Einfach nur so auf hart.
Cooler, macht mehr Fun zu lesen, mit einer Dramaturgie.
Sagt mir am Ende erst, was ich für einen Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen habe.
Sagt mir nicht in Zeile 1, wann er gestorben ist, dass er gestorben ist. Schreibt den Artikel im, so als würde Udo Lindenberg noch leben. Und dann am Ende kommt raus, oh, er war die ganze Zeit tot, what the fuck? Ein bisschen nicht direkt immer mit allen spannenden Informationen um sich hauen. Es ist zu unspannend, das stimmt schon. Es war letztens in einer Buchhandlung, und da gibt es ja auch schon eingepackte Bücher, die dir dann so ein Stichwort geben, wo du noch nicht weißt, was das Buch ist. Da steht ja nur drauf, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Rosinen-Spannung. Erotik-Thriller. Und du denkst dir, was ist an Rosinen-Spannung, das muss ich lesen. Und dann machst du das auf und dann ist es irgendwie ein Kochbuch oder so. Und dann, keine Ahnung, ich habe es nicht aufgemacht, ich habe es nicht gekauft, aber ich dachte mir, geniale Idee. Du kaufst ein Buch Buch ohne zu wissen, was das Buch ist. Du kaufst ein vages Versprechen. Ja, das stimmt. Aber das ist dann oft auch so in Buchhandlungen, die dann tatsächlich so an Bahnhöfen oder so sind, wo man dann, wo man, wo Leute selten nochmal kaufen. Da kann man denen dann Scheiss verkaufen und sie sind nicht wütend. Genau wie mein guter Freund Lars Paulsen, der mal einen langen Flugzeugflug vor sich hatte, irgendwie nach Neuseeland oder so, Auslandsjahr. Und dann hat er beim Buch, dann wurde er ihm ein Buch empfohlen, an der Buchhandlung, es war Twilight. Und er dachte, ah, cool, Action, so Vampire, irgendwie so Horror-Thriller oder so, und hat dann Twilight gelesen, am Ende hat er geweint. Aber das hat er sich nicht erwartet. Das ist halt dann so, du kannst nicht mehr Rache nehmen. Und seitdem muss er immer zum Hamburger Flughafen in die Buchanlage seines Vertrauens gehen. Ja, das stimmt, um sich alle sieben Teile von Twilight empfehlen zu lassen. Ich frage mich, wie Flughäfen, das ist ganz interessant, was da für Städte entsteht, dass man die einfach akzeptiert. Warum? Koffer am Flughafen. Was ist duty free?
Da gibt es keine Steuern auf das Sachen. Das ist so eine Anarchiezone. Da kannst du auch Menschen umbringen. Du hast keine Konsequenzen zu befürchten, glaube ich. Aber ist das so eine Art, das ist so neutraler Boden hier, oder was? So wie auf dem Schiff. Ja, genau. Da existieren doch keine Gesetze. Wie auf dem Schiff. Aber im Schiff war es wirklich so? Der Kapitän kann ich vermählen. Okay, Sie möchten diesen Delfin heiraten? Das ist das Gesetz des Meeres. Da gelten andere Gesetze, das ist das Duty-Free-Gesetz. Stimmt, aber ich bin mit meiner Fähre gefahren, von Frankreich nach England, und da drüben wie so nach zehn Minuten heißt es so Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, jetzt ist internationales Gewässer, jetzt gelten keine Gesetze, und dann kommen die Roulette-Tische raus und die Stripper und alles und dann wird gespielt. Ja, ich muss kurz auf dem Handy gucken, was vielleicht meldet sich Thais gleich Auge geben, sie ist noch nicht da. Aha, ja mal gucken, ob Madame heute noch erscheint. Der müssen wir aber richtig, sag mal, schau mal, wenn du da bist. Die müssen wir aber richtig, ähm, sag ich mal, züge, äh, wie sagt man, rüffeln? Schlägt man noch Schüler, die nicht hören? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Wie sagt man, rüffeln? Ne, rügen, rügen, ja. Ne, aber was machen Kofferläden am Flughafen? Stimmt, ja. Das ist der letzte Ort, oder, also ich habe zum Beispiel, also auf dem Flug nach Mexiko habe ich im Flugzeug, gab es, lief eine Wer für eine Reise nach Mexiko. Ich dachte mir, das ist der schlechteste Ort, um mir jetzt die Reise nach Mexiko geschmackhaft zu machen. Es sind schon bereits Dinge eingeleitet worden, ich bin schon auf dem Weg. Ich kann nichts mehr anderes machen, als nach Mexiko zu fliegen im Moment. Wenn ich jetzt nicht nach Mexiko wollte, müsste ich trotzdem nach Mexiko. Ich könnte mich nicht mehr dagegen entscheiden, nach Mexiko zu fahren. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wer soll da Sitzwerbung machen? Die Bahn? Und dann denkst du dir, wäre ich jetzt gerne in der Bahn. Nee, Venezuela. Und man nimmt die ganze Zeit, fuck, ist es schöner. Und dann stürmst du die Kabine und sagst, wir fahren jetzt nach Venezuela, aber sofort. Und der Kapitän, oh, okay, ich habe heute nichts mehr vor. Ich bin um 18 Uhr wieder in Köln-Bonn. Keine Ahnung, wie das geht. Zeitzonen, Zeitzonen-Magic. Ist das eigentlich immer Winterzeit oder immer Sommerzeit? Ich habe das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe gehört, anscheinend gab es eine europaweite Umfrage, ob das jetzt abgeschafft werden soll. Und irgendwie 80 Prozent der Teilnehmer waren Deutsche. Weil das ausserhalb von Deutschland, glaube ich, entweder niemand mitbekommen hat oder es ist einfach allen scheißegal. Es wird gesagt, Leute, wir verhungern gerade unter einer sozialistischen Diktatur und die Deutschen können sich das leisten hier bei so einer Umfrage. Das ist, glaube ich, unser Nummer eins Problem gewesen in dem Zeitraum. Und es wurde ja auch wirklich von allen Medien gecovert. Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein bisschen der Grund. Das ist ja, wenn jetzt so Tagesthemen entscheiden, Agenda-Setting, okay, das ist jetzt bei uns ein Thema, was uns betrifft, und in anderen kleineren Ländern, wo es dann vielleicht nicht so große Newsanstalten gibt, wird dann einfach dagegen entschieden, das zu berichten. Ich glaube, da kann das schon passieren, dass bei uns einfach so viele Leute abstimmen. Ich habe davon überhaupt nichts mitbekommen. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass wirklich grosse Teile der Informationen an mir vorbeigehen, und ich glaube mittlerweile, ich weiß auch warum, weil ich habe mal... Weil du mir aus dem Haus gehst? Ja, ja, klar. Aber auch, weil ich habe mal anscheinend eine Zeit lang gehabt, wo ich auf Twitter Hashtags blockiert habe. Und mittlerweile reden alle über ein Thema und ich so, was, ich habe davon noch nichts mitbekommen und merke dann, dass ich das Thema blockiert habe. Und ich habe wirklich so einzelne Wörter und Phrasen blockiert und dann kriege ich ganze
geschichtliche Ereignisse nicht mit.
Aber das kann sein, dass du dann sehr konkurrenten bist,
du bist so ein Soldat Nostradamus und du hast alle
spannenden Ereignisse, die passieren könnten,
schon mal präventiv geblockt.
Ich will weder was über Sommerzeit, wenn das Thema aufkommt.
Sommerzeit lohnt sich gar nicht. Warum
blockiert man Sommerzeit?
Was ist in deinem Kopf vorgegangen, von diesem Scheißthema
will ich nichts mehr hören. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Wort
Fussball blockiert, weil mich Fussball
nicht interessiert. Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie
Ich Wie blockiert man Sommerzeit? Was ist in deinem Kopf vorgegangen? Von diesem Scheißthema will ich nichts mehr hören. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Wort Fussball blockiert, weil mich Fussball nicht interessiert. Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie Wasserkrise in irgendeinem Fussballstadion aussieht. Da steigt ja der Begriff Filterblase. Ja, richtig. Das ist so ein Filterkerker um dich errichtet. So eine Bastille-artige. Naja, es ist eigentlich eine Antiblase. Ich schliesse eine Blase konkret aus. Also ich baue kein Schutzschild um mich rum, sondern es ist so ein Lasso. Ich mache Lasso um das Thema Fußball. Ach so, bei Lasso, weil du könntest es auch wieder auflösen. Ich könnte es auch wieder auflösen. Ja, gut. Aber es ist merkwürdig und es ist wirklich, ich muss das irgendwann mal löschen, weil komplette Themenkomplexe gehen vollständig an mir vorbei. Einfach, ja dann... Aber du hast mitbekommen, dass wir im Krieg stehen. Mit Finnland. Wirklich? Ja. Oh, nee. Island haben wir schon eingenommen. Ich habe Island komplett blockiert. Mir interessiert es nicht. Scheiße auf Island. Jetzt haben wir Island eingenommen. Und Finnland droht uns gerade zu überrennen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du es mitbekommen hast. Scheiße, wirklich? Ja. Ich musste lachen, als ich diese Liste durchgegangen bin. Da stand dann, blockiert Hashtag Fussball, Hashtag Fusi, Hashtag Fuppes, Hashtag Kicken, nach dem Spiel ist vor dem Spiel. Hashtag Spölen, Hashtag das Eckige muss ins Runde oder umgekehrt. Hashtag Bolzen, Hashtag Köpper, Hashtag Blutgräte. Hashtag Spaß. Wo ich mir echt dachte, warst du eigentlich ein Schaden? Irgendwie mal so nachts, mitten um vier, sämtliche Synonyme, alle so der... Mit Tränen in den Augen. Ich will einfach nichts mehr hören. Hashtag gelbe Karte, Hashtag blauer Gürtel, Hashtag völlig abgedriftet einfach, irgendwo komplett anders hin. Ach, sei einfach. Und da kann man langsam erkennen, woher die Angst kommt, woher diese Wut auf diese Bürfe kommt. Wahrscheinlich, weil wenn du in diese Liste weitergehst, Hashtag Ex-Freundin, Hashtag VfL, Osnabrück, Hashtag Spieler Frau, Hashtag Schluss gemacht und dann kommt langsam raus. Was hast du gegen Fußball? Ist da wirklich ein Trauma? Nee, ich habe Ich habe nichts gegen Fußball, ich habe nur versucht, meinen Informationsinput zu optimieren, einfach zu sagen, alle Themen, die mich schon überhaupt nicht interessieren, will ich gar nicht an mich ranlassen, weil du liest es ja trotzdem alles mit und du musst ja so ein paar die ersten Begriffe scannen, damit du es dann sozusagen wieder nicht ignorieren kannst. Und es ist lustigerweise ja so, dass da haben sich ja lange gestritten jetzt, ob wir Sommerzeit immer oder Winterzeit immer haben. Und ich glaube, wir haben uns jetzt für das Falsche entschieden, wurde mir gesagt. Ich weiß aber nicht, für was. Wie Herbstzeit. Und lustigerweise hat sich Tschechien vorgeprescht, da jemand gesagt, nö, wir haben uns jetzt entschieden. Wir haben schon abgestimmt, wir haben uns schon entschieden. Und jetzt haben die eine andere Zeit als wir. Fucking Tschechien. Tschechien so, bei uns ist immer elf Uhr, den ganzen Tag. Leute, das können Sie nicht machen. Wir haben uns schon entschieden, sagen die dann. Ja, das ist schon durch unser korruptes Parlament durch. Das ist schon durch unser lächerliches Parlament, wo wir Ei und Ney rufend durch. Nö, ist jetzt immer elf Uhr. Das Abgeordnetenhaus in in in das Abgeordnetenhaus in in Großbritannien ist wirklich auch seltsam. Warum rufen die noch EY und Ney und rufen die ganze Zeit einfach rein? Und warum ist das kein modernes Gebäude, sondern warum müssen die diesem weirden... Es ist super seltsam, weil da liegt dann auch so ein Zepter als Stellvertreter für die Krone, für die Monarchie, für die Königin, so ein Zepter, als wäre die Königin selbst anwesend, stellvertretend so ein Zepter. Und dann kann man es so nehmen und... Richtig, das hat einer gemacht, da gab es so eine Brexit-Verhandlung und einer hat gesagt, Leute, das kommt ja Bullshit und hat dieses Zepter genommen und dann mussten die aufhören zu reden, weil die dann, die hatten dann das Rechtverbot. Die haben noch versucht, mit May rufen, das zu verhindern, aber der hat sich nicht abgeladen lassen. Da kam dann irgendeine schwarz gekleidete Frau, die hat dann gesagt, komm gib's zurück. Und er so, nee, komm, wir können jetzt, was sollen wir machen? Komm, bitte. Unsere Flotte auslaufen lassen, komm. Und dann hat er es aber doch jetzt. Dann kam der schwarze Ritter und dann war alles klar. Naja, das ist schon ein bisschen seltsam. Ich finde, die machen sich da ein bisschen nett. Ach, Thais ist, glaube ich, da. Aha. Die Bahn hat jetzt auch noch Verspätung. Ah, die Bahn hat Verspätung. Da wird aber tief in die Ausredenkiste gegriffen heute. Die Bahn, die sind zehn Minuten da. Vor allem, die sitzen ja, diese zwei Parteien, die blauen und die weiss gestreiften Parteien, die sitzen ja auseinander länger als zwei Degenlängen. Ach so. Das ist genau der Abstand, länger als zwei Degenlängen, damit die nicht während dem Gespräch sich gegenseitig angreifen können. Wenn du mir noch eine Elle näher kommst, dann scheppert das Gewaltig. Ein Fingerbreit von einem Duell entfernt. Ich meine natürlich blöd, sobald Schusswaffen erfunden wurden, ist es natürlichof. Ja, gut. Als einer mit AK-47 da kann ich's machen.
Selbst das da haben sie nicht mehr ... Aber das wäre auch noch lustiger, wenn sie Kilometer weit auseinandersetzen würden.
Was ist die Reichweite von so einer Maschine?
Wenn du mich erschießt, die Kugel ist in der Zeit ...
Naja, es trifft mich nur noch ins Bein, weil die bis dahin abgesenkt.
Ich glaube, es ist ja ...
Gute Frage, wie lange du auseinandersetzen müsstest, damit präzise Schusswaffen nicht mehr treffen.
Glaubst du, du könntest gut schießen? Du bist ein guter Schütze? Ich bin ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr Vater eine Knarre gekauft. Und wir haben im Keller mit so CO2-Diabo los. Warte mal, du bist für das CO2 verantwortlich? Ja, genau. Du hast das ganze CO2 geballert. Das war aber bevor das so ein Skandalchen wurde. Bevor CO2, CO2, Todes, Gas, CO2, wir mögen dich nicht, vor diesem ganzen Zeug. Da wusste ich noch nicht, wie gefährlich das war. Als man noch gesagt hat, CO2 ist die Zukunft. In der Zukunft hat jede Kaffeemaschine CO2. CO2 ist wie Asbest eine wasserdichte Sache. CO2, Asbest und Kontergan, das wird die Zukunft. Also wenn ich Aktien kaufen müsste, dann darf man noch, da kann man drauf bauen. Du hast mit einer CO2-Pistole in deinem Keller geballert? Ja, geballert. Das ist ja nie so schlimm. Da habe ich einfach geknallt. Ja, rumgedödelt. Da haben wir einfach geschossen. Das war einmal lustig und danach haben wir es nie wieder gemacht, aber seitdem glaube ich, kann ich ganz gut, also ich weiß, von Kimmel, von Korn, von dem Trigger, von dem Lauf, da kennt man sich schon aus jetzt. Ich könnte ohne weiteres eine CO2-Patrone reinmachen und auch wieder raus. Und welche Rolle spielt genau das CO2 in der ganzen Sache? Das ist mit Druck halt. Das ist halt so eine Druckluftpistole. Vielleicht ist es auch kein CO2, vielleicht ist es auch einfach Sauerstoff, was doll reingepresst ist und so eine kleine Kartusche, aber dann machst du die rein und dann kannst du halt mit Diabolos schießen. Ich bin mir nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher. Aber wenn die Finnen kommen, nicht an Stefan Wenden. Nee, du, die baller ich euch weg, du, die Finnen. Mit welchem Land werden wir am ehesten noch mal Krieg anfangen? Ja, gute Frage, ne? Jetzt ist vielleicht wahrscheinlich noch mal Luxemburg oder so, die sagen so, oh Leute, jetzt komm einmal noch. Einmal noch. Ich denke mir vor allem, also der Gedanke, mal eben nach Paris zu fahren und es wäre noch Deutschland, ist kein, also ist ein komfortabler Gedanke. Nur mal nur so, also das Gedankenexperiment, ich fahre ein paar Stunden und vielleicht auch an die Côte d'Azur oder mal runter nach Madrid. Ja, aber die hieß dann halt nicht mehr Côte d'Azur, sondern Cozuringen. Blaue Küste, ja gut, aber wäre ja okay. Aber dann hat man einfach, die Währung ist die gleiche, gut, die Menschen sprechen deine Sprache, alle hassen andere Völker genauso wie du. Vor allem ist es ja interessant, dass dadurch, dass wir Land verloren haben vor ein paar Jahren, auch die ganze Dialekte weggefallen sind. So ganz dieses Danzig, Königsberg und so, das ja ganz eigene Dialekte hatte, die sind jetzt alle weg, die gibt es nicht mehr. Weil die, wenn die da nicht mehr wohnen oder das jetzt irgendwie irgendwie Polen ist oder irgendwas anderes. Dialekte gibt es nicht mehr. Ja, weil es halt die langen. Meinst du, du hörst auf, zu sprechen wie ein Hamburger, wenn Hamburg nicht mehr existiert? Ja. Du, ich glaube, dann spricht man immer noch ein bisschen so. Ein bisschen so. Dann musst du halt nach Sachsen fahren, und dann sprichst du wieder ein bisschen Sächsisch. Und dann dann passt du dich ja an. Sprichst du ein bisschen Sächsisch, okay? Also angenommen, Deutschland würde jetzt Frankreich einnehmen und dann würden da Leute hinziehen. Dann müssten die ja sagen, wir brauchen jetzt einen eigenen Dialekt. Und wie entsteht das denn? Würden da alle Deutsch sprechen dann jetzt, wenn Hitler Erfolg gehabt hätte? Würden da jetzt alle... Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Aber so schnell geht das doch nicht. So schnell können nicht einfach alle ihre Sprache vergessen. Und ein Land. Das denke ich mir auch die ganze Zeit, du kannst ja kein Land einnehmen. Ich meine, klar, klar, also du hast halt eine Armee und dann ist deren Armee, so und dann ist irgendwann eingenommen das Land und dann ist deren Armee aber nicht mehr deren Armee, sondern deren Armee sind wir deren Zivilisten. Aber das sind doch immer noch sehr, sehr viele. Du hast ein Land eingenommen, da kannst du noch nicht sagen, und dann ziehst du deinen Truppen wieder ab, und dann stehst du da als Mannequin in Paris, da sagen die ja nicht, ja, jetzt sprechen wir alle deine Sprache. Und übrigens, deine Kultur übernehmen wir jetzt auch alle komplett. Wir sind zwar noch, wir sind 60 Millionen Leute, aber ... Ich glaube, das ist das gleiche Problem, vor dem viele Feldherren der Geschichte standen. Die haben dann überall Brezeln verteilt und dann die Franzosen so, oh la la, peut-être, qu'est-ce que c'est.
So. Hallo, Thais? Hey.
Aha. Die wird jetzt was zuhören bekommen. Die wird jetzt richtig was zuhören bekommen.
Machen wir Good Cop, Bad Cop? So.
Das wird jetzt, jetzt könnt ihr mal zuhören, wie das ist, wenn Stefan und ich, wenn wir richtig fuchsig werden, wenn wir jetzt mal richtig jemanden die Leviten lesen, da werden wir jetzt aber, nee, da werden wir jetzt schon mal ein paar klare Worte finden, glaube ich.
So, herzlich willkommen, bitte schön. Hallo, guten Abend. So, schön, dass du es einrichten konntest. Ja, haben wir Zeit gefunden, mal vorbeizuschauen. Ja, ich bin extra gerannt. Oh Gott, schon okay, kein Problem, ist okay. Du bist extra gerannt? Ja. Na dann, herzlich willkommen im Podcast-Uvo. Danke. Bitte schön. Ach so, ist es schwer. Sag ich so? Ich werde es nicht beschraken, war mit 16. Ich konnte mit 16 so ein Mikrofon noch nicht halten. Ja, hallo, willkommen. Hey, herzlich willkommen, Thais. Ja, danke. Was ist denn passiert? Was ist denn dazwischen gekommen? Ja, also ich war oben und habe noch die Interviews geschnitten. Ah, die Aufgaben, die du gegeben hast. Ja, das hat so lange gedauert. Ja. Und dann, ja. Und dann hast du einfach deine Uhr verloren. Hast du ein bisschen die Zeit vergessen. Ja, und dann bin ich da hingefahren, zum Bahnhof. Und dann ist die Bahn gerade weggefahren. Das kennt man, ne? Das ist immer so ärgerlich. Da ist man genau rechtzeitig da. Aber lustigerweise, wenn ich eine Ausrede suchen müsste, was wäre das Erste, was mir einfallen würde? Die Bahn, klar, die Bahn, weil da kann man sich ja immer darauf verlassen, dass sie zu spät kommt. Ich habe sogar einen Screenshot, dass sie zu spät war. Oh, clever! Ein Screenshot, dass sie, ach so, verstehe. Ja. Dir ist aber schon klar, dass das jetzt einen saftigen Eintrag ins Praktikumsbericht zur Folge hat. Und wenn dein Lehrer anruft, dann ist dir schon klar, dass wir das nicht, die Lehrerin, okay, dass wir das nicht auslassen können, diese Informationen, dass du an deinem ersten richtigen Arbeitstag und dein Arbeitsbeginn war um 19 Uhr, findest du das eine unangenehme Zeit, findest du das eine Zeit, wo man zu spät kommen kann, 19 Uhr? Ja, ähm, jetzt tut mir leid. Ist okay, sind schuldig. Ja, wir haben dir eine Aufgabe gegeben, du bist jetzt seit drei Tagen hier Praktikantin, Montag hast du angefangen. Wie geht's dir? Gut, aber ich war heute echt gestresst, weil die Rentner alle so schwammig geantwortet haben. Komm drauf. Und du musst dich halt das Beste rausschneiden. Die haben Zeit, nicht wie du. Ja, wir haben dir eine Aufgabe gegeben, damit wir verstehen, warum du von Rentnern redest. Wir haben dir eine Aufgabe gegeben, und zwar solltest du für heute ein Audio-Feature erstellen. Und da hast du einige Leute interviewt und geschnitten. Wir sind sehr gespannt darauf, was passiert. Wir werden das genau so, wie du es uns abgibst, senden. Ich bin sehr gespannt, aber lief es okay? Bist du zufrieden, wie es geworden ist? Ja, jetzt bin ich stolz drauf. Du bist stolz drauf? Stolz drauf sogar. Gut, cool. Sehr gespannt. Das freut mich. Kannst du mal sagen, was die Aufgabe war? Genau. Ja, also ich sollte die Rentner interviewen, warum sie das Podcast-Ufo nicht hören und was sie mal besser machen kann. Ja, das stimmt, weil wir haben nämlich herausgefunden, dass wir haben ein Riesenproblem. Wir haben ein Riesenproblem im älteren Sektor. Und ich muss sagen, also das... Ich hätte sehr viel Angst, dass ich diese Statistik gelesen habe, weil, klar, demografischer Wandel, die Menschen werden immer älter. Und wir haben ein großes Problem, weil niemand über 60, ich glaube, über 50 haben wir ein Prozent unserer Hörer sind über 50. Ja, das ist ganz katastrophal. Die hassen uns, man kann sagen, das Podcast wird gehasst von älteren Leuten. Wir achten uns, jede ältere Person, der sich in der Straße begegne, ein ganz verächtlicher Blick. Es ist so, als ob sie den Hashtag das Podcast-Sofo gesperrt hätten bei Twitter. Fast so ist es. Da müssen wir einfach was machen, weil demografischer Wandel, die alten Leute werden immer mehr, die jungen Leute werden immer weniger, die jungen Leute sterben uns weg und die alten werden immer mehr. Wollen wir langfristig erfolgreich sein, weil wir müssen über den Älteren ankommen. Wir müssen neue Märkte erschließen und das hat Thais übernommen, denn Thais hat herausgefunden, wo das Problem liegt, weil eigentlich haben wir das Gefühl, dass wir einen sehr ausgewogenen Podcast machen. Dass wir sehr gut sind. Jeder kann reinhören, jeder kann sich das anhören, aber ich glaube, Thais, du hast ein paar Punkte gefunden, die wir vielleicht besser machen können. Ja, es gab schon ein paar Probleme, es gab ein paar Probleme, auf die die gestossen sind. Okay. Ja, hast du denn deinen Beitrag da? Kannst du uns den Schicken? Kannst du uns den Schicken? Ja, kann ich machen. Nimm dir was du trinken möchtest. Können wir danach über diesen Raum sprechen? Ja, gerne, wir können sprechen, worüber du möchtest. Nein. Ungefähr 50 Prozent. Wir sind so ein bisschen, wir haben keinen festen Raum, wir müssen mal gucken, wo Gott frei ist. Ein ziehendes Volk. Ja, nomadisch. Nee, ziehend. Okay, soll ich anfangen? Ja, okay. Hier ist Tais, die Praktikantin vom Podcast-UFO.
Ich bin hier im Auftrag von Stefan und Florentin auf den Strassen Kölns und später im Seniorenkont Düsseldorf, um die Frage zu klären, warum nur ein Prozent der Hörer auf Spotify im Alter zwischen 60 und 150 ist.
Wie wir wissen, wird Deutschland immer älter und deswegen ist es dringend notwendig, den Podcast auch für ältere Generationen attraktiver zu gestalten. Ich hoffe, die Rentner hier können mir bei der Marktforschung weiterhelfen. Entschuldigung, haben Sie ganz kurz Zeit für ein paar Fragen, hier ist die Praktikantin von Podcast-Ufo. Ja. Ja, ich nehme mir die Zeit. Hallo! Haben Sie schon mal was von Podcasts gehört? Nicht so viel. Habe ich noch nicht gehört.
Ich kenne Podcasts, aber.
Was hören Sie denn für welche?
Ich hatte welche über Naturwissenschaften, dann waren Podcasts über Gesundheit, Comedy, also hatte ich Litanur, hatte ich, dann von der Lippe war das, glaube ich, also schon ein bisschen länger her, so kann ich mich jetzt nicht mehr ganz so dran erinnern. Was macht denn Ihre Generation, um unterhalten beziehungsweise belustigt zu werden? Ich lese Bücher, ja, aber jetzt lustig komme ich eigentlich eher nicht. Okay, ähm. Einfach normale Unterhaltung lese ich. Ja, also das ist ja ganz anders als früher. Da hatte man viel mehr Freude an Komödien oder lustigen Sendungen im Fernsehen, wie zum Beispiel das Ohnesoktoat, Theater oder Kuhlenkampf und sowas, was schon sehr, sehr lange zurückliegt. Wenn ich das heute sehe, kriege ich zu viel. Warum denn das? Ja, weil man sich ändert. Im Alter findet man das nicht mehr schön, was man früher schön gefunden hat. Und man ist also sehr wählerisch geworden. Man ist nicht leicht zu belustigen. Und was ich mir gerne angucke, im Fernsehen ist die Heute-Show. Und ab und zu, wenn ich im Auto bin samstags irgendwo hinfahre und länger fahren muss, dann höre ich auch die Kabarett-Sitzungen,
aber da habe ich auch nicht mehr viel Freude dran. Manches kommt einem blöde vor, was man früher schön fand, wie ich schon sagte. normal wie ins Theater zu gehen oder ein gutes Buch zu lesen.
Ja, also ich denke mal, eine gute Satire ist sehr schön.
Also ich stehe nicht so auf flachen Humor, die ältere Generation wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Das will ich dann ja eigentlich schon zur älteren Generation gehören.
Okay, ich denke, meine ältere Generation ist wahrscheinlich noch mehr im Radio verhaftet. Sport, wandern, walken, singen und irgendwelche Medien, die Sie sich anhören oder anschauen. Also wir hören sehr viel Radio. Finden Sie den Namen Podcast-Ufo ansprechend?lege gerade, warum der UFO heisst, Unterseeboot. Oh, UFO heisst ja Untersee. Nee, Unknown Flying Object. Wollen Sie mal ganz kurz reinhören und sagen, wie Sie es finden, was Sie gut finden, was Sie schlecht finden? Ja? Ich bin ein Freund der Impulsivware im Supermarkt. Ich kaufe mir so eine Kinderregel-Dublo, aber das Problem an denen, dass sie immer recht warm und weich sind. Also was mache ich? Clever, Wagen voll, ich gehe bald zur Kasse, ich hole mir den Dublo und lege ihn noch schön ins Gefrierfach, schön zwischen die tiefgefrorenen Pommes, ja, zwischen die tiefgefrorenen Pommes dazu, dann lege ich alles auf die Kasse, habe dann noch genug Zeit, um wieder zum Gefrierfach zu gehen,
schön zwischen den Pommes rauszuholen und einen knackig kalten Kinderriegel. Wie oft hast du es vergessen, sei ehrlich. Ja, ich habe es tatsächlich einmal vergessen. Es ist wie so ein Eichhörnchen, was ich überlege, ich lege mir das zurück und dann sagt die Eiche, ha ha ha, neuer Baum! riesigen Packungen Pommes, Tiefkühlpommes, die wurden gerade befüllt. Ich stand wirklich wie angefroren daneben, weil ich mir bei einem Tag dachte, das ist mein kleines Geheimnis, das ist zwischen mir und dem Kinderriegel, das darf niemand wissen. Und dann tatsächlich wirklich wie in einem Film, und ich garantiere euch zu 100% dass es war, die Frau geht auch genau über dir zu dem Ding, macht auf und sortiert erstmal die um, Ja,t die erste Packung Pommes runter, sieht direkt meinen Kinderriegel, guckt auch Günther, wir haben drei Achter, drei Achter Alarm, da kommt das Milchglas und der Kinderriegel, macht genau, und fragt es dann weg. Aber das machen wir auch so, aber wir tun den nicht zwischen die Pommes, wir tun in den Kühlschrank. Und, also wie fanden Sie die Show? Äh, ja, geht. Also Sie haben jetzt ein paar Mal geschmunzelt, fanden Sie es gut? Ich glaube, ich habe den ganzen Gag nicht so voll mitgekriegt. Ein bisschen gestresst, weil sehr schnell gesprochen wurde. Jetzt muss ich, ob ich darüber lachen kann oder nicht. Ja, generell nicht. Ja, und was finden Sie, muss noch verbessert werden oder geändert werden, damit ältere Generationen da mithören? Ich glaube, das Entscheidende dabei ist das Tempo. Ja? Ich glaube, dass es besser wäre, wenn Inhalte, die man langsamer transportieren könnte, dann auch langsamer transportiert werden.
Was das ist, was er sich da gekauft hat, da fehlen mir schon die Vokabeln und dann habe ich es hinterher verstanden.
Das geht ja jetzt in die witzige Richtung, soll es nur witzig sein oder?
Ja, nur witzig.
Ach so, es soll nur witzig sein, okay. Tja, hm. Also ich denke mal Familie, Mann, Frau, das ist immer witzig. Man kann auch sich selbst auf den Arm nehmen, das Alter selber auf den Arm nehmen. Ja, vielleicht doch ein bisschen Musik dazwischen tun. Und was für Musik? Ja, auch gemischt, ob Schlager oder Hip-Hop oder was weiss ich, Rock, alles Mögliche, man kann ja mischen. Der visuelle Eindruck fehlt. Also das war ja im Grunde genommen, das war ja wohl eine Live-Veranstaltung, oder? Ja, genau. Und wenn es eine Live-Veranstaltung ist, dann ist natürlich klar, dass die Leute, die im Zuhörerbereich oder im Zuschauerbereich sitzen, dass die da auch gestik Mimik mitbekommen.
Und insofern ist es schwieriger nachzuvollziehen, die Pointen zu treffen, beziehungsweise zu verstehen, wenn dann wirklich die visuelle Ebene fehlt. Wenn man über Tiere spricht, über was weiss ich, witzige Katzen-Demos oder wenn Hunde irgendwie Kunststückchen machen oder weiß ich nicht, also so in die Richtung. Okay, dann vielen Dank. Sind Sie mit einverstanden, dass das veröffentlicht wird? Ja, ist ja kein Name drauf. Nee. Also Leute, ihr habt es gehört, das Podcast-Ufo darf nur noch langsame, eindeutig lustige Folgen über Tiere mit Video- und Schlagerpausen machen, damit es nicht ausstirbt und Chancen in der Zukunft hat. Bis dahin lassen wir die Alten noch ein bisschen hier im Kurs sein. Mega gut! Vielen Dank! Sehr, sehr gut. War das dein erster Beitrag? Sehr schön. Den du jemals geschnitten, fantastisch geschnitten. Richtig gut. Ich fand das richtig toll. Richtig guter Aufbau, hat Sinn ergeben. Ja, ich hatte von vorne bis hinten ein großes Interesse, vor allem, weil es uns selber betrifft, aber interessant. Okay, also wir fassen zusammen, wir müssen viel, viel langsamer sprechen. Florentin? Wie vielen Leuten hast du den Ausschnitt aus dem Podcast vorgespielt? Acht. Acht Leuten? Ja. Du saßt achtmal dabei, wie jemand diesen Ausschnitt gehört hat und du saßt dabei. Ja, es sind immer verzweifelte Gesichter, die nicht wussten, was sie tun sollen. Die gehen wollten, aber nicht... Ja, soll ich jetzt lachen aus Höflichkeit, soll ich ... Oh nein. Warst du vorher die Bremsen an den Rollatoren festgezogen, oder warum? Die Krücken weggenommen. Aber interessant, also klar, ich hab mir schon vieles gedacht, muss ich auch sagen, will ich bestimmt auch. Ich mein, dass die Themen nicht die richtigen sind, vielleicht Schlagerpausen, hab ich auch schon oft vorgeschlagen, hat Florian sich nicht durchringen können.
Ich war echt immer gegen Schlagerpausen, aber jetzt geht auch Hip-Hop.
Hip-Hop geht auch, ja.
Das hat mich verwundert. Kam das häufiger? Ist Hip-Hop mittlerweile so ein Thing?
Ne, nur einmal, aber...
Und Katzendemos?
Ist Hip-Hop offiziell tot, wenn eine Rentnerin vorschlägt, Hip-Hop zu spielen in einem Podcast?
Ich glaube, das war's.
Das ist auch ihre Agenda wahrscheinlich, Hip-Hop zu töten. Heute an diesem Tag ist Hip-Hop gestorben, am 13.2., das war's. Aber kannten die Leute Podcasts, oder war das auch schon ein Problem? Nee, ich muss das jedes Mal erklären, jedes Mal ein bisschen anders, weil ich finde es sehr schwierig, das zu erklären, einmal habe ich gesagt, so ja. Zum Baum, irgendwann hast du keine Lust mehr gehabt. Wie im Radio, zwischen der Musik. Wie im Radio. oder Shows ohne Bild. Das geht einfach nicht. Man kann es sich gut erklären. Wahnsinnig spannend. Hast du das Gefühl, dass wir, wenn wir diese ganzen Sachen einhalten, wirklich eine Chance haben bei älteren Leuten? Ja. Also bei den Jüngeren glaube ich nicht mehr so. Weil wir die verlieren langsam. Ja, aber Deutschland wird ja eh immer älter, deswegen ... Du hast ganz ernst gerade gesagt, dass wir die Jüngeren verlieren? Ja. Also deine Generation. Ja. Dich verlieren wir? Wir haben keine Chance bei deiner Generation. Wir sind cool, ich benutze Snapchat. Wir sind trendig. Ich hab Snapchat, ich schreib DMs, ich slide in DMs. Ich mach Posts und Picks. Ich hörre Ariana Grande und Ken Drake. Was machst du, Gifs? Ja, eigene. Bis in 2016. Aber du sagst, wir haben mehr Chance bei den Rentnern als bei deiner Generation. Ja, also wenn ihr das alles umsetzt, dann habt ihr mehr Chance bei der Rentner. Ach so, das heißt, wir müssen uns entscheiden, wir können nicht beide einfangen. Ja. Vielleicht hätten wir auch noch eine über jüngere Generation machen sollen, eine Umfrage. Wovor interessieren sich denn deine Generationen, was sind so Themen, wo wir ... Wir wollen ja alle haben, wir wollen jetzt, sag ich mal, mit dem Hang Schlagerpausen. Hip-Hop wäre zum Beispiel eine Sache, wo vielleicht beide drauf einspringen können, die Alten und die Jungen. Wir haben schon mal gefreestyled. Ja, aber Hip-Hop ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so, eher Rap. Okay. Eher so Lil Peep, Lil Pump. Lil, für Lil, für kleines Zeug. Ja. Kleine Künstler. Okay. Lil Pump? Ja. Ja. Lil Peep? Ja. Lil Wayne? Ja. Ja. Also alles, was Lil ist, ist im Grunde passabel. Ja. Okay, okay, interessant. Aber so thematisch, was sind so Themen, für die sich deine Generation interessiert? Wir haben von den Alten gehört, Tierthemen und Katzen-Demos, was zur Hölle auch immer das sein soll. Was sind so die Themen deiner Generation? Wir wollen nur Viskas. Ja, also ich würde sagen, es gibt nicht so viel. Eher Smartphones. Okay. Ja, Snapchat, Instagram. Aber generell, was alle interessiert, gibt's glaube ich nicht so viele Themen. Ich hab auch das Gefühl, dass die Themen so ein bisschen diverser werden. Drogen. Drogen? Klar. Drogen? Okay. Also nicht für mich. Hast du schon mal Drogen genommen? Nö. Nee. Ja., aber Drogen ist eher so. Macht ja, aber aus deiner Stufe viele? Klasse? Das ist nur in der Klasse, ne? Nee, Stufe. Ach so, ja klar. Drogen ist schon ein gutes Thema, könnt ihr alle mit reinziehen, ich glaube auch die ältere Generation. Ja, okay. Das ist gut, das ist gut zu wissen. Ein bisschen befremdlich von den 16-Jährigen zu hören, dass wir über Drogen reden müssen, aber...
Wir sagen, wir machen erstmal eine kleine Schlagerpause und dann sind wir wieder zurück zum Drogen-Talk und dann sollten eigentlich alle zufrieden sein.
Haben wir ein bisschen Schlager da? Gibt es Gema-freien Schlager, den wir jetzt spielen können?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich dachte, Schlager ist...
3-3-3.
Okay.
Ich suche einen Schlagersong für uns raus, der Gemama Freis, bei dem ich euch jetzt viel Spaß wünsche. dann fühl ich mich ohne dich.
Nur mit dir sind mir die Träume von der Liebe,
wirklich nah, bleibe hier, bleib bei mir.
Wenn ich das nur wüsste, ob es dir genauso geht, warum sagst du niemals, wie es um uns beide steht? Ohne dich bin ich allein, wenn andere lachen, so allein fühl ich mich ohne dich.
Doch ein Wort von dir kann mich so glücklich machen, sag es mir, bleibe hier, bleib bei mir. das auch besser erklären. Ja, übrigens, ich habe auch eine andere Aufgabe erfüllt, nämlich ich habe Stars angeschrieben auf Instagram, aber sie haben leider noch nicht geantwortet. Hat niemand geantwortet? Außer eine, ich habe den Namen vergessen. Es war deine Aufgabe, uns ein paar Gäste zu besorgen, denn was immer gut ist, ist natürlich berühmte Gäste, grosse Gäste, und Thais ist mittlerweile unsere PR-Beraterin, die natürlich auch Leute heranholt, also die Gäste organisiert. Sie ist Redaktionsleiterin, hat somit natürlich die Aufgaben, Gäste zu organisieren, Gäste zu betreuen. Wen hast du angeschrieben? Was ist noch, worauf dürfen sich die Hörer freuen? Ja, also auf jeden Fall, weil GNTM ja gerade eben gerade anläuft. James ist Topmodel. Den habe ich auch geblockt, das habe ich auch nicht mitbekommen. Ja, da habe ich Heidi Klum auf jeden Fall angeschrieben. Sehr gut, aber hat die jetzt gerade nicht was zu tun, wenn die gerade läuft? Ist die gerade nicht schwanger? Ja, ich schlafe nicht so viel. Die ist schwanger? Weiß ich nicht. Sagt man, von Tom, Kauditz, ich weiß, ich kenne mich aus. Dann habe ich noch die anderen Juroren, also die Ex-Juroren angeschrieben. Ganz kurz, kannst du kurz vielleicht mal vorlesen, was du Heidi Klum geschrieben hast? Ich habe alle aber die gleiche Nachricht geschrieben. Das ist immer gut, das zeugt von großem Respekt. Aber du hast auch allen anderen Liebe Heidi geschrieben, was vielleicht ein bisschen... Genau, genau. Gibt's hier WLAN? Gibt's hier WLAN? Ich kann hier kurz einen Hotspot machen. Komm, die Erwachsenen geben dir einen Hotspot. Danke. Guck mal, hier kommen zwei Generationen zusammen. Ich muss gleich noch mein Datenvolumen benutzen, um zurückzuführen. Ach ja, stimmt. Nach Düsseldorf. Hatte ich früher auch nicht so viel Datenvolumen. Das ist aber ein wichtiges Thema für die jungen Generation, Datenvolumen, oder? Ja, obwohl die meisten endlos haben. Was ist das bei mir? Mein Passwort für mein Hotspot ist Thais1234, was ein bisschen seltsamer zufällt. Das hat überhaupt nichts mit dir zu tun.
Ah ja, Larissa Derries hat geantwortet. Oh, wirklich? Ja, gut, okay.
Ich wusste, dass ich ...
Vom Instagram-Account aus das Podcast-Ufo, den du angelegt hast.
Du hast von uns einen Instagram-Account angelegt.
Danke dafür.
Folgt dem auch alle mal.
Und von dem aus hast du dann Leute angeschrieben.
Genau. Okay. Und wir haben noch keinen blauen Haken, deswegen ist es, glaube ich, ein kleines Problem. Also ich habe geschrieben, hey Heidi, hier schreibt die Praktikantin vom Podcast-Lufo. Meine Aufgabe ist es, einen Stargast für die nächste Folge zu finden. Immer schön einschneiden. Hättest du eventuell Interesse... Womit hast du dich eingeschlagen? Ein Stargast. Ach so, okay, ja gut. Okay, okay. Hättest du eventuell Interesse, einfach mal in einer Folge ein bisschen mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Wilze quatschen? Du weißt schon, die beiden. Die Artillerie haben ja einfach mal die großen Namen rausgeholt. Ja, also ich habe noch Barbara Schöneberger geschrieben auf jeden Fall. Sehr gut. Ist sie beliebt in eurer Generation? Babsi? Nee. Und vielleicht für die älteren noch mal ja elias ein barek der ist beliebt emma schweiger die ist auch toll bin ich nicht die einzige kleine hier dann pamela reiff so eine sport instagramerin oder youtuberin und es hat nurissa Ries geantwortet? Ja, bis jetzt.
Okay. Aber hat sie sich denn positiv?
Also will sie denn kommen oder nicht?
Ja. Ja, wirklich?
Sie hat eure Nummer.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber danke, dass du den Kontakt hergestellt hast.
Sie war auch schon mal im Podcast,
bevor aber immer gerne den Kontakt nochmal. Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Doch, klar.
Das stimmt nicht.
Natürlich mit ihrem Hund.
Natürlich bei Larissa Ries im Podcast.
Hallo?
Nein.
Nein, sie war noch nicht im Posten.
Doch, natürlich.
Ich finde es auch lustig, dass du eine konkrete, falsche Vorstellung hast, dass du wüsstest, wie es abgelaufen wäre, mit Hund, klar.
Nee, sie war noch nicht da.
Das kann nicht sein.
Ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher.
Mit Hund.
Oben in dem Studio oben und der Hund sass hinter mir. Klar, mit Hund. Und es war der 13. Februar 2015. Nein, sorry. Das kann nicht sein, ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher. Mit Hund?
Oben in dem Studio oben und der Hund sass hinter mir.
Klar mit Hund.
Und es war der 13. Februar 2015.
Nein, sorry.
Rockstar war da.
Und der hatte ihren Hund.
Das kann sein.
Da hört man sie aber kurz im Hintergrund.
Stimmt.
Ja, so.
Das zählt.
Aber okay, sorry.
Haben wir kurz dich und die alten Leute verloren.
Sonst wäre ich sehr ins Fettnäpfchen getreten.
Das stimmt. Das ist kein Problem. Ah, aber wie, was hast du noch so dich und die alten Leute verloren. Sonst wäre ich sehr ins Fettnäpfchen getreten. Das stimmt.
Ah, aber wie, was hast du noch so, also ich sag mal, ich find's total cool, dass du dich bei uns beworben hast, weil das ist, ich hätte mich damals glaube ich nicht getraut, so ich habe gerade schon erzählt, als du zu spät kamst, wo ich damals ein Praktikum gemacht habe, ich hätte mich wirklich gefreut, bei sowas Praktikum machen zu können und deswegen bin ich gespannt, was hast du noch so vor, Wir haben dir ja ein paar Möglichkeiten gegeben, und du kannst ja noch viel machen, und wir haben dir auch viele Freiheiten gegeben, muss man sagen. Wir sind sehr liberale Chefs. Ja. Was hast du noch so vor, was möchtest du machen, wie möchtest du deine zwei Wochen nutzen bei uns? Hast du noch große Pläne? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich habe heute das Auktionshaus angeschrieben. Das ist ein kleiner Teaser für nächste Woche, da musst du nämlich noch ein Audiofeature machen, genau wie heute. Wir sind noch nicht geantwortet, aber vielleicht morgen. Super. Und ja, morgen gehe ich ins BTF. In die Bild-Antonfabrik? Ja, und gehe dann in die Maske und schaue mal da was. Ah, cool. Ja, sehr schön. Du hast noch ein paar Sachen gesammelt, du wolltest ein paar Fragen aus der Community einholen, habe ich gesehen.
Du bist natürlich auch für die Community verantwortlich, hast du deinen Twitter-Account übernommen.
Und es war deine Idee, ein paar Fragen aus der Community zu angeln, finde ich sehr gut, dass wir auch die Community so ein bisschen integrieren.
Haben die geantwortet zu deiner Zufriedenheit?
Ja, sehr viele Nachrichten sind eingegangen. Wie sieht man hier die Nachrichten? Das können wir dir beibringen. Das ist Wahnsinn. Denn darum geht es ja auch im Praktikum, dass man Dinge lernt. Bei uns lernst du, wie du Instagram-Account erstellst. Das ist jetzt der Tweet und da kannst du alle Antworten darauf eingehen. Das ist Wahnsinn. Man denkt immer, die junge Generation ist so Social Media, aber Twitter ist dir völlig fremd. Ja, völlig. Das ist unglaublich. Ich verstehe auch nicht den Reiz so richtig daran. Da machst du jetzt beliebt bei den Leuten, denen wir auf Twitter antworten. So, jetzt lest du mal die Twitter-Antworten vor. Ja, ich suche kurz mal gute raus. Ja, viel Erfolg. Ja, das kann ja lange dauern. Das wird dauern. Sag mal. In der Zwischenzeit noch ein Schlagersong, viel Erfolg. Ja, das kann ja lange dauern.
In der Zwischenzeit noch ein Schlagersong. Viel Spaß. Weisst du noch, wie unser Glück begann? Leicht und unbeschwert fing alles an, Und wir spürten beide dieser Traum mit wahr, Liebe für ein Leben, gross und wunderbar. Jede Tag mit dir bringt Sonne in mein Leben, jeder Augenblick ist voll Musik. Was meinst du eigentlich, was fehlt Katzen eigentlich so, was meinst du, geht's denen gut oder organisieren die sich politisch irgendwie, meinst du da gibt gibt's Möglichkeiten? Klar, deswegen würde ich sagen, wir gehen mal zur grossen Rubrik die Top drei Katzen-Demos 2003. Also bei mir auf jeden Fall in Bayreuth die grosse Katzen-Demo. Ja, wir erinnern uns, zur Türe rein, zur Türe raus, zur Türe rein, wieder raus. Gebt uns so eine kleine Tür, wir kommen nicht an die Klinke. Die Türen sind zu klein. Wir wollen mehr zu essen, die Türen sind zu klein, lasst uns wieder rein. Das war catchy. Hat aber nichts bewirkt. Also muss man sagen, deren Protesterfolg ist recht gering. Atomkraft, uns egal, wir wissen nicht genau, was es ist. Fand ich auch gute Katzen-Demo. Das stimmt, ja. Hast du was gefunden? Ja. Wer von euch beiden würde beim Armdrücken gewinnen? Definitiv. Definitiv du. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Wollt ihr es mal ausprobieren für die Insta-Story? Nee, kann man... Okay. Solange könnt ihr beantworten, ob Ananas auf Pizza gehört. Nein, definitiv nicht. Nee, wir müssen die runter machen, glaube ich. Du bist ja Sportstefa, du hast dich jetzt irgendwie wieder angemeldet und machst einen Elektrosport. Du hast gesagt, du machst Elektrosport, wo du irgendwie hier so unter Strom gestellt, in so einem Badeanzug. Ja, Sport machst, da habe ich doch keine Chance gegen deinen Elektroarm. Da kann ich mir was zu erzählen, außerdem war ich sehr erzürnt über die Community, du hast ein Bild von mir hochgeladen, ohne mich zu fragen. Ja, das ist mir auch noch regel. Florentin hat geantwortet, für dich, wenn man die Tinosität. Ja, natürlich, wenn Florentin das bescheuertes Bild von der Welt von mir hochladen darf, aber da hat jemand drunter geschrieben, wow, Stefan hat echt zugenommen und ich habe elf Kilo abgenommen. Ich habe elf Kilo seit Dezember abgenommen. Ja, aber sieht man auch. Danke schön, danke, Thais. Du hast ja Muskeln wieder zugenommen, das gleicht sich ja wieder aus. Ja, aber in meinem Gesicht doch nicht. Wo ich in meinem Gesicht... Nee, du bist echt sehr dünn geworden. Ja, ich finde es einfach wahnsinnig traurig. Ich wollte es so nicht sagen, als ich reinkam beim... Es wäre ein weirder Beginn. Ja, aber das war das Erste, was du sagen wolltest, als du ihn gesehen hast. Von wem kommt denn die Frage? Das musst immer dabei sagen. Das ist immer wichtig. Community-Bindung ist immer wichtig. Ja, das kann noch ein bisschen dauern. Dann denkt der einen aus. Gute alte, gute Arbeit, Impro-Regel. Denk scheiße einfach drauf. Von Maya Biene. Von Maya Biene, vielen Dank Maya Biene für diese fantastische Frage, wir werden es rausfinden. Ich zähle an. Es muss mittig sein, beide mittig sein. Ja, okay. Ne, du musst schon mittig sein. Eins, zwei, drei. Ich will es nicht anfeuern. Das ist wahnsinnig weh. Okay. Oh, oh, Florentin hat gewonnen.
Ja, dankeschön.
Meierbiene, vielen Dank für diese Ich werde es nicht anfeuern. Ah, es ist wahnsinnig weh!
Oh oh, Florentin hat gewonnen. Ja, dankeschön.
Meierbiene, vielen Dank für diese Frage.
Oh Stefan, hey Stefan, du bist ein netter Typ, okay?
Hey Stefan! Als der Armdrück begann.
Leicht und unbeschwert fing alles an.
Okay, vielen Dank für Thais' Community-Ecke,
für diesen kleinen Ausflug, was unsere Hörer so denken.
Wir hatten so einen wahnsinnig ehrgeizigen Lehrer,
der hat mit einem Schüler mal Armdrücken gemacht. Der Schüler war offensichtlich stärker, es war einfach so ein Riesenschrank und tatsächlich hat Burkhardt, der Lehrer, hat dann gebrochenen Arm gehabt, weil er, und das ist einfach, muss man sagen, deswegen habe ich auch gerade im richtigen Moment aufgegeben, weil sonst brichtete er den Arm, weil Armdrücken ist einfach, also es ist einfach ein Loose-Loose-Game eigentlich. Hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt.
Wie gross ist Florentin von Ray...
Ich kann auf meinen Ausweis schauen.
Nee, wir können diese Mess-App nutzen von IOS.
Also auf meinem Ausweis steht 1,72.
Willst du mal ein altes Foto von mir sehen?
Hübsch. Du musst mir Reaktionen, Audio Audioreaktionen zeigen. Da war ich so alt wie du. Da war ich 16. Bist du ausgewachsen? Ist man mit 16 ausgewachsen? Ich weiß nicht. Du weißt nicht, es sind noch ganz lange Arme, die wachsen noch einen Meter einfach. Also ich bin jetzt 1,70 ungefähr. Kommt hin. Ja, und ich hoffe, dass ich nicht noch mehr wachse. Du willst nicht noch mehr wachsen? Gross sein ist keine Schande. Warum willst du nicht noch grösser werden? Ja, irgendwann ist auch die Grenze erreicht als Frau, finde ich. Also für mich. Nichts gegen die anderen draussen. Okay, ich finde es interessant, dass du ganz konkrete Vorstellungen hast, wie groß du gerne sein würdest.
Ich finde auch gut, dass du dieses Ziel auf jeden Fall erreichen wirst. Das ist auch das Gute an so einem Ziel.
Dass du irgendwann sagst...
Ja, aber was passiert, wenn ich da übers Ziel hinausschiesse?
Er ist ja unwerscheinend.
1,71. Was auch noch oft gefragt wurde...
Du kannst gerne den Namen dazusagen, von dem, der die Frage gestellt hat. Habe ich gerade eben. Achso. Okay, gut. Was auch noch oft gefragt wurde, was ich aber gerade hier nicht finde, ist, ob man das Poster vom Podcast UFO auch irgendwann online erwerben kann. Bislang ist es exklusiv ein Tourposter. Tut mir leid. Ist Stefans Vater Hausmeister? Nein. Von Stefan gefragt. Nein. Wird es 2019 ein Hörspiel geben? Von Andre Candidus. Bestimmt. Oder? Oder zwei. Kleinen Vampir? Oder wenn mein Vater der Hausmeister ist. Der Hausmeister findet im Dachboden
einen kleinen Vampir.
Und dann freunden die sich an.
Und der Hausmeister ist die einzige Menschenperson, die der Vampir kennt.
Und dann liest der Vampir dem Hausmeister eine bessere Geschichte vor.
Um die es dann eigentlich geht.
Über Magier.
Nee, die Biografie von Abraham Lincoln.
Und Abraham Lincoln sitzt am Bett von seinem Sohn und liest ihm eine Geschichte aus dem Geschichtbuch vor.
Ja, damit kann man noch arbeiten. Das finde ich nie so schnell.
Hat Florentin Joyce Ilk irgendwann noch einmal getroffen und kennt sie die Joyce-Ilk-Geschichte?
Ich habe sie danach noch einmal getroffen bei Rocket Beans.
Von Ali K.
Ja, ich habe sie noch einmal getroffen, aber ich habe es nicht übers Herz gebracht, das anzusprechen, unsere alte Begegnung. Und somit bleibt das weiterhin ungeklärt. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie davon weiß, von unserer damaligen Geschichte. Bin mir nicht sicher. Ich hab sie auch angeschrieben auf Instagram. Sehr gut, sehr gut. Wie viele Leute hast du angeschrieben? Ich muss einfach nur copy-pasten. Ja, aber ich musste immer den Namen ändern. Ungefähr 35. 35, da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit schon hoch, dass wir irgendjemanden kriegen. Vielleicht haben wir nächste Woche einen Stargast. Haltet die Augen offen. Es passiert mir immer, wenn ich suche eine neue Wohnung in Köln, und dann kann man halt, muss man bei Immobilienscout, kann man immer diese, wenn man eine Wohnung anfragt, kommt dann immer eine automatisch generierte Nachricht.
Und das Einzige, was nicht gerne wird, ist der Name. Und der erste Name, den du dann oben eingibst, der bleibt dann einfach immer bei jeder Wohnung. Das ist mir aufgefallen, bei Wohnung 80 ist mir eingefallen, dass ich immer Frau Stadel geschrieben habe. Und das ist, naja, ich glaube, da habe ich schon viele, viele gute Karten aus der Hand gegeben, auf jeden Fall, bei dieser ersten falschen Begrüßung. Ja. Also immer darauf achten. Kleiner, sehr spezieller Tipp. Heute ist ja übrigens unsere große Spezialfolge, ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mitbekommen hast, heute unsere große Valentinstag-Folge, denn heute ist Valentinstag. Ja. Und deswegen heute Thema Valentinstag, unsere große Sonder-Special-Folge.
Ja.
Und ja.
Also der heilige Valentin.
Eine Sache zum Thema Valentinstag, das grob dazu passt.
Ich habe immer in der Live-Show erzählt von dieser einen jungen Dame, in die ich damals verliebt war, die aber sehr dumm war. Was natürlich schlecht ist, weil man kann sie nicht ausdrücken, wenn man sich verliebt, und wenn man sich halt dummerweise in jemanden verliebt, der nicht so klug ist, ist es halt blöd. Stellt sich raus, diese junge Dame hört das Podcast-Ufo. Nein, nein. Fucking hell, ich möchte auf der Stelle sterben. Und hat sich bei mir gemeldet. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie in dem Moment rausgefunden hat, dass ich in sie verliebt war oder nicht. Ich glaube, das hat sie schon gemerkt. Zumindest hat sie herausgefunden, dass sie sich für Stroh dumm hält. Sie hat auch zumindest herausgefunden, dass ich fünf Minuten vor 1000 Leuten erzählt habe, wie unfassbar dumm sie ist. Liebe Grüße, Frau Doktor, Doktor. Ja, nee, stellst du dich raus, sie hat dich angeschrieben und sie hat tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich, da läuft es dir eiskalt den Rücken runter, wenn du die Nachricht morgens bekommst und die, dass der Bildschirm flimmert auf Facebook und sie hat geschrieben, ja, du hattest recht, ich war damals wirklich ziemlich dumm. Okay. Sie hat geschrieben, ja, sie hat gesagt, sie hat sich mittlerweile geändert. Wenigstens hat sie es eingesehen. Ja, sie hat es eingesehen, ja. Das ist schon Zeug von charakterlicher Größe. Ja, wirklich, finde ich auch. Vielleicht hast du einen großen Fehler begangen. Ich würde auch sagen, dass ich mit 16 komplett bescheuert war. Jeder ist mit 16 komplett bescheuert. Ja, jeder ist mit 16 komplett durch. Und alles, was man denkt, wird sich noch ändern in den nächsten Jahren. Ja, und lustigerweise willst du alles, was du jetzt gerade machst, irgendwann mal hassen. Du willst irgendwann mal sagen, warum habe ich das gemacht? Und lustigerweise wissen das ja 16-Jährige mittlerweile auch. Du bist ja der Welt mehr ausgesetzt, als wir damals mit 16 waren. Und du weißt Dinge. Und man ist ja, ich glaube, man ist nicht reflektierter, aber man hat zumindest die Chance. Du hast ja nicht das Gefühl, dass du alles, was du gerade machst, auch überspringen kannst. Du kannst auch, das macht das Gegenteil. Das ist mein Rat alle 16 Jahre daraus. Macht das Gegenteil von dem, was ihr gerade machen wollt. Es ist wahrscheinlich besser. Oder was du mit 13 gemacht hast, wirst du ja auch jetzt nicht mehr abfeiern, wie Jugendliche sagen. Ja, also ich habe gerade eine Phase hinter mir. Mein Leben besteht auch aus Phasen. Sehr gut. Und meine Phase im Moment, oder naja, die ich jetzt abgeschlossen habe, war die Punkphase. Ah, okay. Das ist doch ein Thing. Nee. Nee, nee, also Punks. Ja, genau, also nicht so richtig. Green Day hören und so. Ja, also bei mir ist es jetzt vorbei. Aber das Doofe ist, ich habe meine Nase gepierst und Winterschuhe gekauft, Doc Martens mit roten Schnürsenkeln und die Schwarzen weggeschmissen. Ah, okay, das heißt, du bist jetzt momentan noch in so einer Übergangsphase, so Halbpunk. Oh, das kenne ich sehr, sehr gut. Und ich habe gerade eine Zwischenphase, ich weiß, wie ich es tun soll. Aber was ist die nächste Phase, was kommt nach Punk? Ich weiß es nicht. Also du legst momentan nur Punk ab, aber du nimmst noch nichts Neues an.
Genau, ich bin im Moment nichts.
Aber Punk ist ja auch ein Musikgeschmack.
Ja, ich habe es damals gefeiert, aber jetzt, wenn ich es höre, denke ich so, hm.
Zu aggressiv.
Vor zwei Tagen.
Ja, es geht dann schnell, ne?
Ja.
Und was hat dazu geführt, dass du gesagt hast, ich will kein Punk mehr sein?
Gab es da irgendein Erlebnis, das dich verändert hat?
Ja, ich habe einen Freund von einer Freundin getroffen, auf einer Demo und...
Katzen-Demo?
Nein, dieser Fridays for Future Demo, die nicht richtig punkig ist, aber ja, also er hat dann so ein Mikrofon gebrüllt, so alle Konzerne geht kaputt und so und dann habe ich auf seine Schuhe geguckt und dann waren das Timberland Schuhe und ich habe so, okay, dann war die Demo vorbei und sein Vater kam mit dem Auto, um ihn abzuholen. Und ich weiss nicht, ob ihr die Fridays for Future Demos kennt, aber das ist gegen Umweltverschmutzung.
Und wenn sein Pfad ihn extra aus der Düsseldorfer Innenstadt holt, die eine sehr gute Bahnverbindung hat, hat es mir schon zu denken gegeben und dachte so, ja. Und dann hast du gesagt, nur wegen dieser einen Person, die unkonsequent ist, sagst du. Ja, ich habe gesehen, dass die meisten Heuchler sind. Okay. Aber braucht dann die Bewegung nicht mehr, also warum sagst du dann der Bewegung ab und sagst nicht einfach, die braucht mehr Leute wie ich, die es ernst meinen. Ja, also das hat mich auch ziemlich ... Deswegen meine ich, alle Entscheidungen, die du gerade triffst, sind dumm. Versuchst du nicht wieder zum Punk zurückzubringen. Ich glaube, sie macht hier gute Fortschritte. Nee, du verstehst, was ich meine. Du hast ja total die richtigen Gedanken über diesen Heuchler. Ja. Aber stattdessen sagst du ... Gut, aber dass du deswegen deinen Musikgeschmack änderst, das ergibt für mich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig Sinn. Dass du sagst, ich lege jetzt meine Identität ab, nur weil jemand anders, der dieselbe Identität hat, inkonsequent ist. Ja, aber alle waren ... Also ich habe dann gesehen, dass alle ungefähr gleich inkonsequent waren. Mhm. Und ja, die Musik habe ich eigentlich nur gefeiert wegen der Nachrichten, die sie überbracht haben. Mhm. Ah, okay gesehen, als ich abends noch unterwegs war, dass ein paar Punks auf der Strasse waren, die aber ein bisschen verloren aussahen.
Und dann ging ein Businessmanager mit einem Koffer an ihnen vorbei, ziemlich gehetzt.
Und dann dachtest du, der will ich sein.
Ja.
Und dann dachtest du, ich will lieber der Businessmanager sein.
Ich will lieber gehetzt sein, als die, die nichts zu tun haben, die verloren sind. Du kannst auch als Punken vollen Kateriegeländer haben. Ja, also Punk macht auch ziemlich depressiv, also nicht, dass ich depressiv war, aber schon niedergeschlagen, weil man sich halt mit allen schlimmen Themen auf der Welt auseinandersetzt, wie zum Beispiel Hunger in Afrika, Ungerechtigkeiten. Und da hattest du, dieser Businessman
macht alles richtig. Scheuklappen auf,
nach vorne laufen, nicht nach rechts und links
gucken. Mach dich das
nicht zu einem grösseren Heuchler,
den ich persönlich nehme, als den Typen.
Naja, aber jetzt ist es ja sozusagen,
jetzt bist du konsequent auf der bösen
Seite. Du bist nicht mehr inkonsequent
auf der guten Seite, sondern nächste Woche kommt sie
ja rein und hat irgendwie Häkler und Kochaktien
unter dem Arm und sagt, ja so Freunde, jetzt aber
Dachs geht hoch. Nee, auf allem, ich finde es lustig, wenn du
Aber Bösenseite. Du bist nicht mehr inkonsequent auf der guten Seite, sondern nächste Woche kommt sie ja rein und hat irgendwie Häkler und Koch Aktien unter dem Arm und sagt ja so Freunde, jetzt aber DAX geht hoch. Ich finde es lustig, wenn du irgendwann in so einem, weiss ich nicht, genau so ein DAX-Unternehmen sitzt und dann fällt dir auf, Moment, der trägt keine Timberland-Schuhe, der trägt diese recycelten neuen Schuhe, die ich bei Instagram gesehen habe, die komplett CO2-neutral gestellt werden und und dann sagst du, Leute, nein, nicht mit mir, und dann bist du wieder bei einem Plan, und dein Leben ist ein großer Kreis und Pendel. Es gibt immer wieder Momente, wo du siehst, verdammt, der trägt diese Schuhe, und dann ändert sich dein ganzes Leben. Das wird jetzt noch häufiger passieren. Aber wäre das was für dich als nächste Phase, so wirklich Hardcore-Kapitalismus, jetzt Konzerne, Amazon-Aktien kaufen? Ich habe da noch so eine Zwischenphase. Die wohl noch die Dogmatens aner. Bis du aus den Dogmatens rauswächst. Aber das kenne ich gut, dass man Phasen hat und dann trägt man so Dinge mit sich. Und dann hat man die halt noch ein bisschen. Das ist normal. Das Boosted Board? Das Boosted Board liegt auch bei mir zu Hause rum. Das ist kaputt gegangen eigentlich. Nee, das ist nicht kaputt gegangen, das Harborboard ist kaputt gegangen, aber habe ich jetzt verkauft. Das habe ich verkauft. Und dann lustigerweise habe ich das bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen verkauft und dann kam, hat mich eine Frau angerufen, mitten in der Nacht, hat gefragt, ich muss jetzt vorbeikommen, das Harborboard abholen. Und ich dachte mir so, ja, weil ich in dem Moment wollte es einfach nur loswerden und habe gesagt, ja, okay, alles klar. Hier fährt kein Zug mehr, ich brauche jetzt ein Hoverboard. Und dann kam sie mitten in der Nacht zu mir in einen ganz anderen Stadtteil von Köln, um das Hoverboard zu kaufen. Dann war sie da und hat sie gefragt, können Sie kurz rauskommen? Ich bin mit dem Hoverboard unterm Arm nach draußen gegangen und habe es ihr gegeben und dann hat sie gesagt, okay, hier ist das Geld, das wir ausgemacht haben, ich habe es jetzt aber nicht passend. Können Sie mir wechseln, können Sie mir wechseln? Und ich hab gesagt, ja, okay, bin mit dem Hoverboard unterm Arm wieder zurückgegangen, um Portemonnaie zu holen und sie hat gesagt, dann lassen Sie das doch hier und legen Sie es schon mal in den Kofferraum. Und da war wirklich so ein Moment, wo ich dachte, wo ich mich gefühlt habe wie ein Bendersnatch, wo ich dachte, oh, ja gut, ich kann meine Entscheidung treffen, ich muss nicht das Harborboard hier lassen, ich kann es auch wieder mitnehmen, habe es dann aber da gelassen, weil ich dachte, das ist so clever, ich gönne ihr diesen Erfolg irgendwie, wenn sie damit wegfährt, dann bin ich ganz schnell rein, bin ich gerannt, ich habe es da gelassen und immer, wo ich es losgelassen habe, bin ich in meine Wohnung gerannt, bin wieder zurückgerannt mit dem Portemonnaie und dann war sie noch da und hat mir das Wechsel gegeben.
Und dann hast du gesehen, was ich für Schuhe anhatte und dann dachtest du, ich muss mein ganzes Leben ändern. Was passiert in ihrem Leben, dass man mitten in der Nacht ein Hoverboard braucht? Dass man sagt, so mein Leben ist eigentlich fast perfekt, ich habe einen guten Haarschnitt, ich habe elf Kilo abgenommen, das einzige, was mir fehlt, ich brauche ein Hoverboard. Die war so Mitte, Ende 30, würde ich sagen, und die hat die ganze Zeit gesagt, er kam gerade noch mal an und hat gesagt, ich brauche das jetzt, ich brauche das Board jetzt. Und gestern hat er auch schon zu mir gesagt, dass er es unbedingt wollte, aber da haben sie mir nicht geantwortet. Und heute hat er es noch mal gesagt, und ich weiß bis heute nicht, wenn sie meinet, meinst ihr ihr Kind, aber was für ein Kind sagt, ich brauche jetzt ein Hoverboard. Also sie hat das Kind nicht nachgeäfft, wie man das halt so von Kennt, von Müttern, sondern sie hat einfach gesagt, als wäre es ein wie ihr Mann. Aber das war kaputt. Das war kaputt, das letzte Mal war kaputt, dann habe ich mir ein neues bestellt und da habe ich das verkauft. Ist das ein Thema für eure Generation, Hoverboard? Hatten schon ein paar die coolen Jungs, ne? Nee. Die uncoolen Jungs? Nein, also ich kenne gar keinen mit einem Hoverboard. Fidget Spinner ist das noch ein Ding. Hula-Hoop-Reifen, was ist so der heiße Scheiß? Was ist der heiße Scheiß am Schulhof? Noch dieses Kästchen, wo man so springt mit einem Bein? Käsekästchen, Schiffe versinken? Gras. Okay, gut. Wirklich? Interessant, bei uns war das kein grosses Thema, wirklich, Drogen an unserer Schule. Wenn, dann hat Gras, aber nie chemische Drogen. Ist das so ein Ding? Nee, gar nicht, ne? Ecstasy, LSD, Ritalin? Nee. Auch nicht? Achso, Ritalin, äh, nee, aber mein Bruder kriegt das was geschrieben wahrscheinlich. Kann ich ein paar ... Kannst du verkaufen, um die Schule. Kannst du ein paar klar machen. Da habe ich recherchiert und habe gelesen, dass sehr viele Jugendliche das mittlerweile nehmen, zum Lernen und zum Ausstudieren. Ist das der Leistungsdruck hoch, Zukunftsangst?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, weil, also ich bin auf einer Art, also meine Schule nennt sich selber Elite-Schule, ist aber ...
Ist aber keine.
Nee, nee.
Aber Elite ist falsch geschrieben.
Nee, es ist halt keine richtige und die machen einfach nur unnötig Druck und ist aber nicht wirklich gut. Aber nach wie vielen Jahren machst du Abitur? Mit wie vielen? Nach wie vielen Jahren? Zwölf oder dreizehn? Ach so. Nach acht nehme ich an, oder? Geacht? Ja, geacht. Und deswegen habe ich dreimal die Woche bis siebzehn Uhr Schule. Ja, hatte ich auch. Wow! Was ziemlich anstrengend ist und deswegen hat die Jugend von heute nicht so viele Interessen mehr. Mir gefällt es nicht, wenn die Jugend von heute spricht. Ja. Das hat nichts befangen. Es gibt gar keine richtigen Hobbys mehr. Ja, das stimmt. Sportverein stellt immer aus. Ja, also es ist einfach nur in die Schule gehen, da bleiben, zu Hause gehen, Hausaufgaben machen. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Sport, aber dann wird es auch schon kritisch. Aber ihr habt zumindest Zeit, auf Demos zu gehen. Ja, aber bei der Fridays for Future Demo schwänzt man ja die Schule. Wird das was mit der Demo, bringt das was? Ja, weiss ich nicht. Also es werden immer mehr Leute. Und wie viel Prozent machen das jetzt so in deiner Stufe, die dann freitags schwänzen und demonstrieren? Also von hundert ungefähr drei. Drei? Sich, zehn, aber inklusive du? Ja, aber ich war nur zweimal da, weil unsere Schule ziemlich Stress macht. Deswegen.
Aber wie viele von denen, warum spielen es nicht einfach alle und dann gehen einfach die meisten nach Hause und spielen Play-Z? Ja, stimmt. Das sollten wir mal einführen. Ja, das wäre mein Tipp. Bleib mal dabei, ich finde es nicht schlecht. Ja, ihr könnt auch kommen, ne? Zieht das mal durch. Ja, wir haben halt Arbeit und leider keine Lust. Ja keine Lust. Aber ist schon krass, bestimmt auch schwer für die Lehrer, weil die ja an sich natürlich ob ihres Berufsweges dagegen sein müssen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn die Kinder da wären, würde ihnen beigebracht werden, wie schlecht es ums Klima steht. Und dann ist es schon so ein bisschen Widerspruch, oder? Das ist ja das Clevere der Jugend an dem Moment. Dass sie die Erwachsenen mit ihren eigenen Waffen schlagen. Mit ihren eigenen Ideologien erpressen, um frei zu haben. Das ist schon sehr clever. Entweder willst du von der französischen Revolution lernen, oder du gehst auf eine Revolution. Das ist schon so. Praxiserfahrung. Also ich freue mich total, was du noch nächste Woche, du bist auch noch da bei uns. Ich freue mich sehr, was du noch so mitbringst, was deinen Beitrag macht. Ich will noch nicht zu viel verraten, aber es wird, glaube ich, sehr interessant. Ich glaube, es wird richtig gut. Vielleicht haben wir einen Stargast. Vielleicht sitzt Uli Hoeneß nächste Woche hier oder irgendjemand anderes. Du kümmerst dich noch um Sponsoren. Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert. Vielleicht werden wir nächste Woche gesponsert. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Und ansonsten wünschen wir dir sehr viel Erfolg für deine zweite Woche. Genau. Das Podcast-Ufo-Praktikum. Die erste Woche ist ja noch ein bisschen. Ja. Aber viel Spaß. Und wenn du nichts zu tun hast, sag Bescheid, dann versorgen wir dich mit Aufgaben. Ja, danke. Aber ich glaube, du machst das auf jeden Fall gut. Also der Beitrag war mega. Er war richtig gut. Es war wirklich wesentlich besser, als ich dachte. Ja. Ich dachte, da kommt ein komplett unzusammenhängender Zusammenschnitt einfach nur von 40 Minuten lang, einfach nur alle O-Töne, die du aufgenommen hast, aber da war System drin.
Es war richtig gut geschnitten, ja. Und am Ende mit dem Chor rausgehen, das ist schön.
Ich dachte kurz, du nutzt das so ein bisschen zum Slacken
das Praktikum, weil am ersten Tag
kam ein Tweet,
aber, und da muss ich sagen, der Beitrag
war heute wirklich toll, also da werde ich auch dem Lehrer
sagen, ich werde dem Lehrer auch sagen, dass am ersten Tag
nur ein Tweet kam und dass du heute zu spät kamst,
ich werde aber auch sagen, dass der Beitrag ganz toll war.
Wehe, du gehst am Freitag demonstrieren, okay?
Wenn du am Freitag schwänzt bei uns...
Bist du raus.
Dann, bis nächste Woche.
Wir wünschen dir eine schöne Woche.
Danke, gleichfalls.
Willst du diese Woche mal abheben?
Du darfst abmoderieren, du darfst abheben.
Du darfst abmoderieren, ja.
Dann, bis zur nächsten Woche, Leute.
Wir heben alle gleichzeitig ab.
Ja.